no
[Music]
the body reacts to anything foreign
first of all it wouldn't be sterile
so you would probably develop a massive
infection related to that junior mint
outside of that the body does react to
it and would form scar
around it and probably an abscess around
it
hey gq this is dr leonard lee and this
is the breakdown
first up doctor strange
the reality is is that we never wash our
hands without a mask on
the point of washing our hands is to
clean our hands and obviously the mouth
has a lot of bacterial flora
and bacteria that can get on our hands
so we would never wash our hands
go into the operating room gown put on
sterile
gloves and then touch our mask that just
wouldn't happen
where do you store all this useless
information useless the man charted a
top 10 hit with a fool horn
status billy 1977. oh please i hate you
there's a lot of casual banter in the
operating room and this
actually does happen it's not always so
intense that we're continuously focused
for the entire duration of the operation
but we are able to have some casual
conversation in the opera room
and this helps to keep people relaxed so
that if
stressful circumstances were to arise
that they would then be ready to act
dr west cover your watch
some surgeons are very sensitive to
noise in the operating room some
surgeons demand absolute silence in the
operating room while they're doing their
procedures
other surgeons listen to music and have
a little bit more of a casual
environment
not that the operation is any less
serious
but it's a little bit of a lighter
atmosphere that other people may feel
more comfortable working in
you can't do it freehand i cannot i will
so she's actually at the operating room
table without a mask on
and although it's nice to be able to see
her face that would never happen in the
operating room
what is it dsw
amazing kept him alive left a bullet in
his head thanks
we never say gsw it's a gunshot wound
neurosurgeons heart surgeons vascular
surgeons a lot of surgeons do
utilize the magnification with the
glasses they're not as dramatic looking
as his are
or stylish as his are but we do
routinely use them in the operating room
that's called a ranger and that's
actually an instrument that
neurosurgeons do
use orthopedists use it also heart
surgeons use it for certain valve
procedures the instrumentation is
actually pretty correct there are
computer screens in the operating room
that allow us to view
images but less so real time the way
they
showed it here where his forceps are
actually going into the brain and you
see it on the monitor
going into the brain to grab the bullet
we don't have that type of sophisticated
monitoring but the rest of it is
actually not bad
i did not agree to that i don't need you
to we've already called brain death
prematurely we need to get a prep for
suboccipital cranial
not gonna let you operate on a dead man
so brain death criteria is a
very very complicated thing it requires
six to twelve hours of examinations
three or four
different physicians coming in and
evaluating the patient
it requires a time to lapse
between evaluations and that's why it
takes that six to 12 hours
we want to make sure that the patient is
truly
brain dead so that circumstances like
this
would never happen next up train wreck
we're gonna get this going okay perfect
um i'm gonna mark the knee that we're
gonna do the surgery on
right marking actually is something that
takes place
preoperatively so this is actually
fairly accurate we do
confirm with the patient that we're
operating on the right side of the body
on the right part of the body so that we
don't make mistakes
and that's why there are so many safety
checks once we get into the operating
room there's a procedure called timeout
and the timeout
once again confirms we have the right
patient for the right operation
we have all the instruments and all the
equipment that we need for the operation
and that everybody's on the same page
all these safety checks have been
implemented by the world health
organization
and these are world wide safety measures
that we now all
implement and practice so that we want
to minimize the things
like wrong site surgery this is the
wrong knee i'm working this is not the
need to do this is not this knee
this is gonna go great this is the bad
boy we're gonna split open
there are always new stories about
operating on the wrong side of the
patient
removing the wrong organ these are
obviously
absolutely disastrous complications
something that no surgeon would ever
want to be involved in
i'm here for you okay you're nervous i'm
nervous
surgeons never tell a patient that
they're nervous even if it's true we
want to
reassure the patients comfort the
patients telling a patient that you're
nervous is probably the last thing you
would want to do
i said you got to let me go to sleep i
have a surgery and you know what she
said she said
no hey i'm taking a raincheck we never
want to be in a situation where we're
fatigued going into the operating room
unfortunately
there are always circumstances where
that can happen
if you've had an emergency the night
before and then you have early morning
surgery the day after
it can happen hopefully however your
judgment would tell you that if you are
too fatigued that you either postpone
the operation
or have one of your colleagues perform
the operation the next morning
it's not unusual for a surgeon to work
60
70 hours a week which means night time
getting called in for emergencies or
weekends getting called in for
emergencies when
it's your turn to take call next up is
seinfeld
so this is probably one of the most
famous
medical surgical scenes that has ever
been
played on tv there would never be a
reason
for a gallery to be in the operating
room sharing the space
and if they were in the operating room
they would all be masked and out of the
field of view
where'd you get those the machine you
want one no
there would also never be food in the
operating room these are all no-no's and
that can
all lead to breaks of sterile
environment
no sleepers stop it
the body reacts to anything foreign
first of all it wouldn't be sterile
so you would probably develop a massive
infection related to that junior mint
outside of that the body does react to
it and would form scar
around it and probably an abscess around
it
we're very cautious not to leave
instruments or
sponges or anything like that in the
body the body will always react to these
things so there are counts
at the beginning of surgery the numbers
of needles on the field the number of
instruments on the field the number of
sponges on the field everything that we
would use in the operating room for the
purposes of performing the operation
is counted at the end of the operation
prior to closing the patient
all of these things are accounted again
we'll open the peritoneal cavity
exposing the body's internal organs
nurse retractor
the operating room environment is
primarily the surgeon's responsibility
so anything that happens as a
consequence of the operation
is going to fall on the shoulders of the
surgeon he's in charge of everybody in
the operating room
he's like the captain of the ship or the
conductor of an orchestra everyone is
taking the orders from the primary
surgeon
next up the good doctor
[Music]
she is a surgical resident and this is
obviously
one of her first more major operations a
first
big operation would perhaps be a
memorable event
it's probably more memorable however for
your first operation
as an attending surgeon which means
after you're done with all your surgical
training
you are now an official surgeon on your
own and that first operation is the most
memorable
is everybody ready for a time out
dr claire brown lead surgeon dr neil
melendez attending surgeon
dr sean murphy assistant
so i wish every time i walked into the
operating room it was quite
a processional like that with people
waiting on you
and hand and foot but it's never quite
that dramatic
the timeout process is something that
happens every day however we don't
introduce ourselves it's all known who
we are
the other thing is that the timeout
would be done prior to the patient
going to sleep being anesthetized so
this patient is already under general
anesthesia
we have the patients participate in
their timeout process
so that they hear it and they know that
we know what we're doing
dr jan lancaster anesthesia donna
petringa scrub nurse
shanie weldon circulating nurse the
number of people in the operating room
is dependent upon the operation
it would be very rare to have that many
people in the operating room
scrubbed at the table the most common
circumstance is
a primary surgeon perhaps a resident and
maybe one other resident or an assistant
of some sort
and then one scrub nurse and those would
be the only people who would be
sterile at the operating room table the
other people would be an
anesthesiologist
and then what's called a circulating
nurse that nurse is responsible for
being
in the operating room but not sterile at
the operating room table
his or her responsibility is to get
equipment and supplies for the people at
the operating room table should they
need anything
next up spies like us the first step in
an operation of this particular type
is
[Music]
to shave the patient ah forget i forgot
to get on with it
it may be obvious to some but not
obvious to others that when we talk
about shaving the patient we're talking
about
shaving the surgical area so his abdomen
would have been shaved so that there's
no particulate matter there's no hair
in the way because the hair and the hair
roots can be quite dirty so we want to
make sure that that area is shaved clean
and now the first incision
so even under battlefield conditions the
same
tenets of sterile technique would hold
true the patients would be prepped
meaning they would be shaved they would
be cleaned antiseptic would be applied
to the wound
masks would already be on the gown and
the gloves would all be sterile so they
wouldn't be touching all sorts of other
things like books and manuals they would
only touch things within the sterile
surgical field
and they would certainly not be putting
their masks on after they're down and
gloved so the mask that everyone
is wearing for covid are general use
masks the masks that loop around the
ears
they're a little bit less tightly woven
than the masks that we use in the
operating room the masses
that we use in the operating room tend
to be specifically designed
for the operative environment to
minimize
the likelihood that bacteria or bugs
from your mouth get into the surgical
field because that's the primary purpose
of it is to keep the surgical field as
clean as possible so they are a little
different but in principle it's the same
[Music]
thing
this man is dead
[Music]
so if there were ever a situation where
the patient died in the operating room
we would all jump on that patient start
cpr immediately we wouldn't just say
oh well they died let's move on so cpr
is
short for cardiopulmonary resuscitation
and that's a way of
getting the heart going in a situation
where the heart has stopped
most patients are candidates for cpr
it's a very very rare circumstance where
we would not do cpr
and those are primarily patients who
have what's called
an advanced directive which means that
they have decided
beforehand that if their heart should
stop at any time
that they do not want any invasive
procedures they don't want anything done
extraordinary
to save their life a lot of that
decision making depends upon
the disease state the patient has the
age of the patient
other medical issues they may have the
patient's wishes beforehand
how long we've been trying to get them
back we've been doing the cpr
and trying to get them back all of these
impact our decision making as to when to
give up often involves
multiple people being involved in that
decision making
and it's it's not something we take very
lightly at all
the second step in an operation of this
type
is
anesthetic we would never be in
a situation where we are referring to a
manual during the course of an operation
there are operations that we don't
necessarily perform very often
and when we prepare for surgery we do
review some things
about the operation and that's not
unusual that's all done
in pre-operative preparation we might be
able to get that source by googling the
problems with things that are posted
online that
is that none of it is vetted but for
those of us in the industry just like
all of you and your industry you know
what's real what's not real out there
so we can look things up online it can
be also be text it can be journals it
can be whatever
as long as it's a credible source thanks
for watching and stay tuned for part two
where i'll be breaking down more surgery
scenes